[Music]
in hell no news okay I'm excited
submitted by I'm moving what did America
do this time no okay a woman came back
from a vacation with a maggot embedded
in her groin well I'm always so scared
almost you know pictures you got shot in
the [ __ ] was that voice because I never
ever made that voice book I know because
I'm so [ __ ] terrified of [ __ ]
Maggie why I landed in her vagina I'm
not like the spot flies but when you
said that I had a look around who said
that who the [ __ ] said that
[Applause]
that is this that's what Nikki does
about the idea of giving a roach in her
ear she'll freak out yeah we've seen it
on one of our first dates I stepped on a
cockroach and I heard the pop and she
like went like oh like [ __ ] full
house here to do it exactly the way she
did it oh I'm not even kidding she was
like very much she jumped she shakes her
head she's like this she doesn't know
yeah yeah exactly
thank you for telling me that I'm going
to throw is that are you sure I'm gonna
tell her to tickle your ass dude you
should make your ringtone cockroaches
getting stepped on perfectly like on him
snail snail me not you Nikki that
footage needs to be released one thank
you for getting that show picked up by
the way huh you [ __ ] [ __ ] up
ourselves telling the truth we got notes
and they were like who's that guy that
was screaming for the [ __ ] bin you
got to make a whole television show
based on him without you guys did you
going solo
will you go solo absolutely you know I
said I said yo my team rides with me or
I die that's it I've been with these
guys forever I'm ready for my next step
all right so this woman she's 36 years
old she's from Florida oh come on why is
it always full wash there's a lot of
maggots out there it's not her fault is
it her fault no we don't know
I just know that it's Florida so is she
sleeping is she trying to have sex with
rotten food it is her fault so she has
her honeymoon and believe no for maggots
and then two months later is when she
started suffering from itchy and itchy
skin lesion and she went to several
doctors until finally one found out that
there was a maggot burrowed one a make
it Wow burrowed into the skin of her
groin why is her vagina so tasty -
Maggie I don't know I'm talking back
it's like anything that's kind of wet oh
yeah there think they're down for like
anything I probably doesn't clean down
there very well so initially it was a
honeymoon right I feel like she should
be on the patrol for at least you know
like a while you know they just got they
just tied the knot like you know you're
gonna keep it friendly for a bit yeah
hopefully hopefully forever but you know
police especially yeah you're paying to
be there yeah oh what if they got down
with the get-down somewhere weird
oh oh they [ __ ] on the beach or
something that's some weird [ __ ] you see
I also don't like the fact that I wish
like all doctors knew everything so you
have to go like 18 different people and
they're like okay maybe there might be
something wrong it's like [ __ ] her first
doctor they gave her antibiotics and
then you know she finished everything in
the lesion was still there although the
redness did improve and then that's when
she ended up going to the different
doctor and they were like is this assist
and ingrown hair we don't know but then
finally she was able to find out from
this wound healing specialist who
treated her and then that's when they
like they were touching it and it was
hard like the lesion was hard and then
they were like oh there's like an egg or
a bean no one s touched it I don't know
I guess intersession you're a doctor
you're supposed to touch it
no but I'm supposed to look at it yeah
diagnose it
yeah than they thought might touch them
with one of those giant popsicle sticks
let me tell you a joke yeah then that's
when they wait war was like oh so then
they also figured maybe it's a lymph
node problem and then that's when they
discovered it was a maggot and then
she's like really and then she's like
I'm calling the news no this doctor did
a report okay in the Medical Journal of
some sort and then the report came out
guess what was in my vagina oh my god
oh my god that's about to be the next
YouTube challenge Oh true true what in
my [ __ ] yes and they found out that it
was a human you've been bought by BOTS I
told you it was a botfly [ __ ] burrow
under your skin so negative frayed when
they went into the jungle this lady got
botflies this do got a botfly and you
have to get it ripped out I remember
chainmail a nail well back in the day
about botflies [ __ ] me up like I've been
terrified of this and you're gonna show
me a picture aren't you it's a fly that
just sticks onto your skin and you have
to give it bros into your skin it lays
larva in there
well she's naked and just glad that our
chicken so they're saying that insects
like eggs on animals like flies or
mosquitoes and then those insects
becomes a host and then they
transferring it to the human got a
mosquito bite in her crate or something
yeah what was the chain mail like this
remember it was only when I was a kid
and it was saying you don't I think it
was somebody sent you me that picture of
the nipple and it had like a bunch of
holes in it y'all remember that unlike
way back yeah I do yeah yeah you know
that [ __ ] right it went around as a nail
chain mail thing and it said like this
is from a botfly and it was like a woman
like it was just the boob no nipple and
it just had holes and you can see
maggots inside of it
this is from a botfly but Nia she's not
wrong this is what I looked about
looking so this one when it was burrows
I'm not looking they took it out
I don't know that Oh buddy phobia I've
type of photo there's no hole does the
whole whole adult looks like oh you got
more topical areas Santorini no we're
not going there
we're not trying to no I'm good I'm good
that one the larvae they burrow into
human skin and then they live there for
twenty seven to a hundred and twenty
eight days which will make it itchy for
the host and then sometimes patients can
feel it moving and crawling under this
yeah you listen to a queen song over
there when I was a kid I liked like okay
you like sad childhood the book that I
like to read it was only one that was
around with this giant medical book it
was the only book that we had two had
pictures so I would read it so I would
just like I would just look at it all
the time and like I was looking I would
read everything and then in the back
they had all these pictures of like you
know things so that you could identify
them and they were actual photos and
there was like chapters and chapters on
like rashes and like skin problems it's
like that so like I'm like six and I'm
looking at this and I'm like and it's
like you could die for oh it had like
red things and it was like fatal fatal
so now I'm a hypochondriac and I also
hate like flesh wounds like mommy what
Silesian old hate my eyes but flies
first see what did that education give
you only fear only terror yeah it did
well I didn't have anything else to do
Steve no I'm but I'm on your side
I've known about this for so long
they've been a big do you think you have
any in the United States no they don't
know there's been some cases yeah I
especially like like the West Hollywood
Way how are you
yeah so then they're also saying that
local residents and believe they they
are used to this they live there they
just get box wide all the time and so
they have these home remedies because
like what happened to this woman a
surgeon had to make a five millimeter
incision to take it out yeah what is a
home man for this [ __ ] so then what they
do is that they apply petroleum jelly or
bacon strips or nail polish that's like
that yeah that takes first the surgeon
has to prepare their themselves and they
go like doctors everyday don't this is
disgusting so that's why the [ __ ]
first two doctors just said it was a
rash they knew what it was yeah he's
rigged a great talker yeah don't you
like about the [ __ ] out of my office
place yeah
specialist yeah hmm but yeah they're
saying like it's to suffocate it when
they're doing that there's the local
residents and then so after a few hours
is when the head will emerge and then
that's when you take tweezers and then
you dig it up oh the head emerges
nothing should be emerging from my skin
I I didn't sign off on this I don't
think it's okay oh do man that'd be kind
of cool though like if I had a botfly on
my arm and [ __ ] I should see a cop I
might pull that [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] got you [ __ ] yo oh yeah
but he got you worried
Nicky would yeah but Nicky would keep it
as a pet apparently well they're saying
that skin infestation of developing
larvae is the fourth most common skin
among travelers mm-hmm what if you kill
that [ __ ] in you so what's in
here I just I see where you that I grab
my skin and I'm like I [ __ ] punched
your ass and there stay in there [ __ ]
yo you guys remember that scene in like
the matrix where they put the thing of
suck it out like that's that's how I
meant it so when it went in it was worse
for me than when they took it out if
you're crawling in there oh yeah do you
see a little blob moving good with this
topic botflies you don't like the
botflies I don't like any Megan
welcome share in my fear take some of
mine and it was by the groin area yeah
yeah yeah no hate it I don't like it I
was reading this and I was just chased
it whether you have a responsibility to
the viewers I'm not oh come on we'll
send me the link no I'll fax it every
day yeah I'm gonna find it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]